[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Mandalorian season -
ahsoka tano video that's right it really
does seem like ahsoka tano is coming to
the mandalorian season - so we'll break
it all down there's a bunch of Easter
eggs and I'll explain what happened to
her after the events of the Clone Wars
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos they
just finished filming the Mandalorian
season - thankfully before the big virus
hit even though Hollywood's kind of shut
down for a couple weeks so I will talk
about how that's going to affect the
Mandalorian season - timeline this year
so we'll just break this down top 10 WTF
style starting with number 10 if you
didn't see the news this morning the /
film guys broke the news that rosario
Dawson had been cast as a sow Kitano
life action for the mandalorian season -
then all the other Hollywood trades
confirmed the news so this does seem
like a real thing ahsoka is one of the
most popular characters in the Star Wars
universe that they have just not done
live-action yet so it wasn't so much a
question of if they would ever do her
live-action it was just a question of
when and which Star Wars movie or Disney
Plus series they would put her on first
because of their plan for all the Star
Wars Disney Plus series there's a lot of
them that are set or will be set during
her lifetime so there's a number of
different places she could show up
besides the Mandalorian season - after
she shows up on the Mandalorian but it
makes sense that they would put her on
the Mandalorian series first it's the
most popular Star Wars thing right now
so obviously if you want to make a big
splash you put her on the biggest thing
going on number nine most of you know
Dave Filoni from the Star Wars animated
series that he created the Clone Wars
which is currently airing season seven
episodes right now on Disney Plus and
also Star Wars rebels
he's also an executive producer and
co-creator with Jon Favreau on the
live-action Mandalorian series so you
start to see the connection here him
bringing his animated characters to the
live-action series slowly Dave Filoni
actually created the ahsoka character
for the Clone Wars special she's one of
the few Star Wars characters that was
not created by George Lucas so you could
say that she's the character whose most
precious - Dave Filoni he's very
protective of her in the way that George
Lucas was always very very protective of
the Yoda character Poppa bless loved
that picture of
George Lucas on the set of the
mandalorian season - this is from the
mandalorian season - with him cradling
the baby Yoda puppet but when they were
getting ready to premiere the
Mandalorians season 1 back at d23 dave
Loney did several interviews where
people asked him if they would bring
animated characters into the live-action
series this was his answer you see a
world in which someone like ahsoka could
go live-action or anyone else like some
of your animated creations could make
the jump in bicycle
yeah you know Never Say Never
as you can tell from his answer is
basically him chuckling saying yes like
just you wait wait till you see what I
have planned in number 8 here's the
thing - at the time he did that
interview they had already started
working on the mandalorian season 2
episodes meaning they had probably
already signed rosario Dawson to a deal
to play ahsoka we don't know which
episode she shows up in and how many
episodes she's gonna be in during season
2 but the Mandalorian season 2 will have
a tepid stoughton just like season 1 I
don't know how long the episodes will be
because the season 1 episodes were
pretty short from what you would
normally expect but rosario Dawson does
have recent history with the ahsoka
character this whole live-action ahsoka
theory has actually been around for a
long time way back in 2017 she tweeted
this ahsoka lives that was before she
showed up on Star Wars rebels then she
showed up on Good Morning America
actually talking about it with them
questioning her and her saying oh you
know I'm hoping that this bodes well the
Star Wars will cast me as a Sokka in
live-action there's a whole campaign
that's going on online to try to get me
in Star Wars
you know what Star Wars follows you on
twitter I follow anybody Internet
obviously that was why all the new
movies were happening so we always
wondered if she would show up somewhere
in the movies and she kind of did but
not in the way we expected and just for
reference ahsoka
would be in her early 40s while the
events of the Mandalorian series are
going on so she's still pretty young
rosario Dawson in real life is about 40
years old so she's about the same age as
ahsoka would be during the Mandalorian
season to number seven WTF a lot of
people also asking what's going on with
Ashley Eckstein and if they're gonna
pull a Darth Maul live action like they
did during Star Wars solo everyone
remembers at the end of solo a Star Wars
story Darth Maul shows up and it's
secretly revealed that he is the head of
the crimson dawn criminal empire which
sort of flows with what was happening
with him at the end of the Clone Wars
but what they did for that performance
is that they had Rey Park an older Rey
Park in real life come back to reprised
the role as Darth Maul from the original
prequel movies but they also had Sam
Witwer doing the voice so it was two
actors combined to form this one
performance sam witwer had been doing
the voice of Darth Maul for years on
Star Wars the Clone Wars animated series
so because ashley eckstein has been the
voice of ahsoka tano on the Clone Wars
she also came back and did her voice
during Star Wars rebels I've seen a lot
of people in my timeline ask if they're
just gonna dub Ashley Eckstein's voice
onto Rosario Dawson's performance and I
don't think that they're gonna do that
in this case if it were a lesser actor
playing live-action ahsoka I would say
probably yes but the main reason why
they dubbed sam witwer voice onto Rey
Park is because when Rey Park played
Darth Maul during the prequels he was
actually being dubbed then too he's
always been dubbed it's never been rape
arcs real voice as Darth Maul so it's
not quite the same situation with the
ahsoka character but if I hear anything
more about ashley eckstein being
involved with the project i'll totally
do a video about it number 6 WTF what
happened to ahsoka
after the events of the Clone Wars so
right now ahsoka just came back during
the Clone Wars season 7 episode 5 the
episode literally dropped this morning
she shows up in a level 1313
world story Archon Khorasan there was a
bunch of deleted episodes when the Clone
Wars was cancelled so I don't know how
much of the original ideas survived into
the new episodes but her big story line
during Clone Wars season 7 is about her
teaming back up with a Jedi the
Mandalorians in the Republic forces
again to help liberate Mandalore from
Darth Maul and his crime syndicate
forces you may have even seen the
special hashtag the Star Wars created
for Darth Maul's forces this season the
mole DeLorean clearly a joke on the
Mandalorian series this is the way the
Maul DeLoreans are just the special
troopers that worked for Darth Maul that
took his side during this big conflict
and made their armor look like him so
underneath that armor those are just
regular looking Mandalorians serving
Darth Maul but the big final arc for
ahsoka
during this Clone Wars final season is
ahsoka versus Darth Maul they both
survive into the future because both
Darth Maul and ahsoka show up on Star
Wars rebels for a rematch and then
obviously ahsoka now is showing up on
the Mandalorian so we know that she
survives into the future so number 5 WTF
the very last time we physically saw
ahsoka on screen in the Star Wars
timeline is right after the events of
Return of the Jedi in the Battle of
Endor she shows up in this end credits
scene from Star Wars rebels final
episode it's a big time jump and this is
ahsoka in her mid to late 30s this is
the oldest we've ever seen her alive
notice Sabine Wren here also a
Mandalorian I'll talk about that in a
second she's in her 20s when this scene
is happening the events of the
Mandalorian series take place about five
years after this scene so not that much
time goes by but number four that's not
the last time that ahsoka shows up in
the Star Wars timeline the very last
time she shows up is during rise of
Skywalker when Rey hears the voices of
the Jedi calling out to her so if you
haven't seen rise of Skywalker just
careful for spoilers because we'll be
talking about this ahsoka scene so what
happens is Rey is fighting Palpatine in
this big final battle she has to defeat
him the voices of pretty much every
famous Star Wars force sensitive Jedi
character call out to her from Yoda both
versions of obi-wan Kenobi they have
young obi-wan Kenobi played by you and
McGregor but they also have the voice of
older Alec Guinness obi-wan can
in this too so two different OB ones
talking to her ashley eckstein came back
to do the voice of ahsoka tano calling
out to her as well so the fans heard
that and they assumed that that meant
that ahsoka was dead but then right
after the movie came out dave Loney
posted this picture of a souca in
gandalf that he had drawn implying that
ahsoka was not dead
number three WTF what is ahsoka doing
during the events of the Mandalorian
season - if this is five years that's
the last time we saw her assuming she's
no longer traveling with Sabine rent
ahsoka would probably be roaming around
the Outer Rim probably trying to help
people and searching for more Jedi to
survive the purge
we can predict then that along come the
Mandalorian baby Yoda in Moff Gideon in
a mess of trouble with them the
Mandalorian din Joran was given orders
from the armor in the finale to seek out
the jedi so that they could help baby
Yoda and train him as a Jedi seek out
his people ahsoka is probably the former
Jedi that he runs into number two the
siege of Mandalore was referenced on the
Mandalorian episode eight finale by Moff
Gideon they're also covering the siege
of Mandalore during the Clone Wars
season seven final episodes
it's the Republic forces with a sokka's
help in her commando force of clone
troopers laying siege to Mandalore in
order to kick Darth Maul and his crime
syndicate forces off the planet in
number one WTF what happens to ahsoka
after the Mandalorian series the way
they're engineering the Star Wars Disney
Plus series is that there's going to be
some Mandalorian spin-offs any of the
series that take place during her
lifetime there's a Star Wars obi-wan
Kenobi series that she could also come
back on she'd be a much younger version
of the character but they could still
pull that off with rosario Dawson just
using makeup to make her look a little
bit younger
so live-action ahsoka is just the
beginning remember sabina Ren would be
in her late 20s when the Mandalorian is
taking place so they could always do
live action Sabine at some point too
because she's also a Mandalorian just
like din Joran because of the big virus
shutting down Hollywood for the next few
weeks or possibly the next couple of
months
they might wait to drop the first
Mandalorian season 2 trailer till later
this spring or summer but I'll keep
doing bonus videos until then so post
all your reactions to this live-action
ahsoka in the comments and let me know
if you have any big
shins or special requests for videos
everyone click here for my new
Mandalorian season 2 teaser video and
cool behind-the-scenes video and click
here for my new Marvel video on all the
big canceled and delayed movies thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe this is the way
[Music]